[موسيقى]
دخلت المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم السريع اسبوعها الرابع وافاد مراسل
الجزيره بتجدد الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه فجر اليوم
كما حلق الطائرات تابعه للجيش في سماء
الخرطوم والخرطوم بحره وسمعت اصوات اسلحه
ثقيله وخفيفه متقطعه في محيط القصر
الرئاسي ووسط العاصمه ياتي ذلك بينما
تتواصل عمليات الاجلاء وموجات
النزول بسبب المواجهات المسلحه
في الخبر العاجل الذي نقراه على الشاشه
نقلا عن مراسلنا فان داويا انفجارات عنيفه
وتصاعد الدخان يحدث الان في محيط القصر
الرئاسي الخرطوم المزيد انضم الينا منهم
درمان مراسل الجزيره هيثم اويت هيثم اهلا
بك بحسب هذا العاجل اذا انفجرات عنيفه في
محيط القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه هل من
تفاصيل لديه
نعم قبل لحظات قليله من الان كان هناك
سلاح الجو طيران سلاح الجو تابع للجيش
يقوم بالتحليق في سماء منطقه الوسط
الخرطوم ونفذ العديد من الضربات الجويه
على اهداف فيما يبدو لقوات الدعم السريع
وكانت المضادات الارضيه قد انطلقت من تلك
المنطقه بكثافه في خلال الدقائق القليله
الماضيه ونلاحظ اعمده دخان تتصاعد من تلك
الناحيه بشكل كثيف فيما يبدو نتيجه لهذه
الضربات الجويه التي نفذت قبل قليل هذه
الاحداث طبعا تاتي بعد حاله هدوء استمرت
لاكثر من ساعتين او ثلاث ساعات الماضيه لم
تشهد هذه المنطقه اي نوع من الاشتباكات او
المواجهات ما عدا هذه
الضربات الجويه التي فيما يبدو اقامه
المضادات الارضيه بالرد عليها وكلما يحلق
الطيران عاده ما تكون هذه الاصوات الاسلحه
التي تنطلق وما زالت حتى ان تسمع بشكل
واضح من محيط المنطقه فيما يبدو في اطار
هذه المواجهات المستمره والتي تدخل
اسبوعها الرابع الان في ظل هدنه او مجموعه
هدن هشه لم تستطيع حتى الان ان توقف هذه
الاشتباكات والمواجهات بين الجانبين على
الرغم من ان الاطراف الان هي بدات حديث
حول وقف اطلاق النار ووقف هذه الهدنه في
جده بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه ولكن فيما
يبدو على الارض ما تزال لغه المواجهات
ولغه السلاح وصوت السلاح هو الاعلى حتى
الان في هذه في هذه المنطقه
اي بيانات رسميه او اي تصريحات بخصوص ذلك
من الواضح ان شيء من التعتيم يخيم على هذه
المحادثات في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وان الاطراف حتى الان لم تدلي بالتصريحات
رسميه حول فحوى وطبيعه هذه المحادثات ولكن
الواضح ان المنطلقات التي
ذهبت اليها هذه الوفود هناك يعني كانت
الثوابت يبدو انها او مواقف تقول بانها
ثابته لهذا التفاوض بالنسبه للجيش يقول
انه سيفاوض فقط فيما يخص التمديد هذه
الهدن وفتح الممرات الانسانيه الامنه
وتمكين المساعدات الانسانيه من الوصول
وفتح الممرات الامنه وايضا تحسين الظروف
الانسانيه لكنه نفى ان يكون لديه اي نيه
للتفاوض حول اي موضوع سياسي فيما يخص
علاقته بالدعم السريع في المرحله المقبله
وفي الطرف الاخر هناك يقولون انهم يرحبوا
بهذه المفاوضات باعتبارها الدعم السريع
يقول بانه رحبوا بهذه المفاوضات باعتبارها
ستمهد الطريق لتحسين الاوضاع الانسانيه
وقالوا انهم ايضا مصممون على مواصله
الوضيفي اطار التحول الديمقراطي وتشكيل
الحكومه مدنيه انتقاليه في المرحله
المقبله ولكن فيما يبدو هناك طبعا في
وجهات النظر حتى من قبل الاحزاب التي ايضا
هي رحبت بخطوه هذا التفاوض باعتباره مدخل
اولي لوقف اطلاق النار ووقف التصعيد ولكن
ايضا هناك تباينات في الرؤى فيما يخص اذا
كان هناك جانب سياسي في هذا الموضوع هناك
ايضا الكثير من الاحزاب لديها اراء ولديها
يعني
مخاوف اواجس من تعود مره اخرى تفاصيل
سياسيه في هذه المفاوضات عموما الشارع هنا
يترقب الجانب الذي يهم وهو وقف اطلاق
النار ويوقف هذا التصعيد الذي طبعا ادى
الى انعكاسات انسانيه سالبه كثيره جدا
واثرت على حياه الناس على الرغم حتى
المناطق التي لم تتاثر بشكل مباشر
بالمواجهات تاثرت بانعكاسات هذه المواجهات
في الناحيه الاقتصاديه والصحيه والمعيشيه
شكرا لك يا هيثم